bienvenue à La Magnanerie où Laurent et
Laurent ont posé leurs valises ici à
bourrée avec leur chien Laurent il
s'appelle tous les trois Laurent ok
comme on dit à Bruxelles ont tout quitté
de leur Belgique pour réaliser leurs
rêves en commun récupérer un lieu chargé
d'histoire et vivre une vie de
troglodytes et vous allez voir que nos
deux Laurent ne sont pas seulement des
têtes couronnées de laurier mais bien
des passionnés du centre Val de Loire de
son patrimoine de ses rois de ses reines
de ces châteaux et même de
ses séries télé tiens
[Musique]
bon alors racontez-moi la comment on
vient à une vie de troglodyte écoute en
été en Belgique et en 2000 on a
découvert le site lors d'un voyage de
repérage on a trouvé que c'était le
paradis quand ça a été en vente
finalement on s'est dit à pourquoi pas
on change de vie on avait l'âge et vous
avez décidé d'appeler le chat
on y va allez c'est parti
[Musique]
téléphone portable ça passe pas trop
du drame ils vont on se réconcilie
toujours à la fin
bon alors expliquez-moi un petit peu
cette vie là de troglodytes déjà l'été
on est au frais et l'hiver là par
exemple aujourd'hui il fait moche dehors
il fait super bon à l'intérieur par
contre si tu veux qu'on cause un peu roi
reine tête couronnée prince et princesse
c'est pas ici que ça se passe on peut
aller dans la salle à manger allez c'est
parti
les rois les reines et tout comment vous
êtes devenus fan de tout ça les objets
sont jolis tout ce qui a été créés
et c'est combien de visiteurs par an ici
cette année on va arriver à 14000 qui
passe dans notre salon qui passe dans
notre cuisine donc les gens ils passent
par votre habitation c'est ce qui va le
voir et par conséquent je vais aller
voir la cuisine quand même allez c'est
parti
ultra moderne le contraste étonne les
gens pensent que parce qu'on est entre
l'eau on devrait encore être en peau de
bête avec un chaudron alors
qu'aujourd'hui on aménage de manière
moderne les troubles moi je leur dis on
n'a pas le même emballage mais on a même
potentiel c'est très beau ça
oh c'est magnifique
il faut traverser le jardin pour aller
dans la maison bâti j'aime bien quand
des dames qui viennent ici ah mais vous
traversez en pyjama le matin alors je
les regarde sans rien montrer je fais
quel pyjama
pour traverser
pourquoi les Belges ils adorent habiter
dans un troglo alors je ne sais pas
parce que les murs c'est frites
[Musique]
j'espère qu'ici plus